[Music]
I'm actually going to talk about three
somewhat related issues a hair-trigger
alert as advertised also presidential
launch authority and first use options
and the previous speakers have touched
on some of these things so some of what
I say might be a little repetitive but
some of it also bears repeating so let's
talk about hair-trigger alert and launch
on warning the US has about 400 weapons
on missiles in silos underground in the
middle of the country and those weapons
are ready to be launched 24/7 there are
people in underground command posts like
the picture you see here waiting for the
signal to launch in addition some of our
submarine based weapons are on high
alert they could be launched quickly as
well but the ones I'm going to talk
about today are the land-based ones
because those are the ones that really
give rise to a tremendous danger so when
a missile is launched anywhere in the
world the u.s. detects it oh I should
say not a very well actually pretty
short-range missile so we have two kinds
of detectors we have satellite based
sensors that pick up the plume of a
missile and we have radars in different
parts different spaces around the world
and when we detect a launch the clock
starts ticking it takes a few minutes
for us to detect the launch few minutes
for it to be processed by our computer
system
a few minutes for our military advisors
to try the military personnel to try to
figure out what's going on and in the
meanwhile the clock is still ticking it
takes less than half an hour for a
long-range missile to go from the u.s.
to Russia or Russia to the US and these
missiles and silos could be destroyed by
one of those incoming warheads that is
why the clock is ticking okay our
submarine base warheads are not
vulnerable to attack okay so it's really
these land-based missiles that give rise
to this ticking clock shall we say so at
this point maybe 10 minutes has passed
and it's ready if the military decides
that this is a serious alert it goes to
the president you probably have all
heard now about the nuclear football
which is this suitcase carried by the
gentlemen here in the middle of the
screen there's somebody with the
president
24/7 I assume they're not actually you
know I mean anyway with the president
24/7 you can figure that out
ah and the reason is to receive this
alert in this black suitcase is a book
of options so there will be an indicate
you know there the advisors might say we
recommend option 27 but the OP you know
there are lots of options or maybe you
might think of option 54 and then you
can look at what those options are how
many missiles go where you know in some
cases I think it tells you how many
people would die does not tell you what
the consequences but climatic
consequences of such an attack would be
so the president has about ten minutes
to make this decision before he or she
has to tell the Pentagon that yes I want
to launch these missiles okay
now sometimes the sensors are wrong
sometimes other things go wrong and
there have been in the past several
decades nuclear near misses I'm going to
touch on some of the ones we know about
I'm guessing we don't know about all of
them these are the ones that are maybe
the most famous so here's a situation in
1979 and the u.s. received indication
that it was under a full-scale attack it
looked like just the kind of attack they
would be expecting from the Soviet Union
and up goes the alert level and they
figure out that the reason it looks like
an attack because somebody has put a
training tape in the computer and the
training tape is an attack so it looks
just like what they were expecting and
had been training for it did not rise to
the level of the president here's a case
in the Soviet Union in 1983 the
satellites the Soviet satellites detect
what looked to be several incoming
missiles the person in charge that night
in the Soviet command center everything
checked out it looked like a real you
know like there was no corruption of the
data and protocol calls for him to tell
his supervisor and then it would have
gone up from there and based on a gut
feeling he disobeyed the rules and and
decided said oh it's a false alarm
even though he didn't know it's a false
alarm it was a false alarm but he didn't
know
and he was later reprimanded there's a
movie about him the man who saved the
world okay in 95 this is now Russia and
not the Soviet Union um
Norway launched a small what's called a
sounding rocket it was going to do some
scientific experiments in the atmosphere
and its trajectory looked like the
trajectory of a u.s. submarine launched
missile off the coast of Russia that
might have been designed to destroy
Russia's early warning radars as a
prelude to a larger attack and this
warning did apparently go up to Yeltsin
there's a dispute about whether or not
that actually whether it went that far
up Yeltsin says it did people other than
Yeltsin say it didn't it's hard to
imagine the president could be that
confused
right okay so those are cases from the
past what about now this is a quote from
a general Cartwright who used to be the
commander of all the US nuclear weapons
I just let you read it but he's making
the point that cyber attacks are a new
unknown we don't really know how to
factor them in but clearly it's not
going to make things better now our new
Secretary of Defense before he became
Secretary of Defense says something very
interesting in Senate testimony last
year he said is it time to reduce the
Triad to a dyad removing the land-based
missiles this would reduce the false
alarm danger so unfortunately when he
was uh in his confirmation hearings
he was really pounded on this and ended
up saying oh no I believe in the triad
but clearly I think this reflects his
his his own assessment now I don't you
know I don't necessarily think he's
going to act on it but it's a good sign
so now I'm going to talk about the
second thing that I mentioned which is
using nuclear weapons first so a lot of
people think that the US would use that
at the point of US nuclear weapons is to
deter deter what
well deter a nuclear attack on the
United States deter a nuclear attack on
our allies turns out that it's it's more
complicated okay so our previous speaker
said pointed out that in fact you have
had use nuclear weapons first in
Hiroshima and Nagasaki and our policy
has been
we reserve the right to use nuclear
weapons first under the this is the
second Bush administration they they did
a Nuclear Posture review where they
looked at US policy it was leaked and
this is what it says the u.s. reserves
the right to use nuclear weapons first
against any country in response to an
attack with conventional weapons or with
chemical or biological weapons and it
specifically lifted several countries
okay Russia China North Korea Iran who
you know there were no questions about
Iranian nuclear program at that point
Iraq Syria and Libya now what's
interesting is that this policy first
used really flourished during the Cold
War when the US and NATO thought that
Russia had conventional superior the
Soviet Union had conventional
superiority might roll into Western
Europe and that we needed nuclear
weapons to be able to deter that and in
fact at one point the US had 7000
tactical nuclear weapons in Europe okay
now there are only 200 all right so the
policy evolved under the Obama
administration their Nuclear Posture
review which is not classified you can
find it online
says that the primary purpose not the
only but the primary purpose is to deter
the use of nuclear weapons and the US
will not use nuclear weapons against
countries that don't have them so in
other words the US would not use them
against Iraq or Syria or Libya okay so
we take those off the list and in fact
the list it didn't name these countries
but you can figure it out yourself
it would only use them against countries
that have nuclear weapons now there are
only a few that
we whatever attack and they are Russia
China and North Korea
moreover the goal is to have a no first
youth policy got it now President Obama
so this is in 2010 in the last few
months of his administration there was
serious consideration of adopting a no
first use policy Obama was very eager to
do so actually and one of the reasons he
didn't is he got tremendous pushback
from Secretary of Defense ash Carter
Secretary of State John Kerry and
Secretary of Energy Moniz who argued
that this would send the wrong message
to Russia there were tensions with
Russia so we lost that opportunity for
you know who knows how long so let me
move on to presidential launch Authority
now it is the president who has the sole
authority to make a decision that the US
will use its nuclear weapons and I think
Jo talked about this situation earlier
but there is a scary a historical event
in which President Nixon noted correctly
I can go back into my office and pick up
the telephone and in 25 minutes 70
million people will be dead okay he had
the authority to do that
and during Watergate I didn't know about
the talking to the portraits but he was
definitely drinking heavily in a bad way
and Schlesinger told the chiefs of staff
if you get any orders come talk to me
first and that was not legal okay he had
no authority to do that it's unclear if
had Nixon tried to order an attack what
would have happened
okay now let's talk about constraining
presidential launch Authority ah and I
would I would say that we're going to
divide it into two parts nuclear
retaliation
now if so as long as you have this
launch on warning option as long as you
have our missiles on hair-trigger alert
there are only about 10 minutes to make
a decision about launching those weapons
it's totally infeasible that you could
include more than one person in making
that decision okay so as long as we have
that policy we are stuck with this one
person making that decision that's
another reason I think to get rid of
hair trigger alert for our land-based
missiles and launch on warning options
now presumably if there was a decision
to use nuclear weapons first it would
not be you know you would have more than
10 minutes to make that decision and
that opens up the door to constraining
presidential authority in that case
nuclear first use and we've already
heard there is legislation restricting
the first use of nuclear weapons act
sponsored by Senator Markey our own
senator and representative Liu one
minute and it would prohibit the
president from launching a first strike
without congressional declaration of war
and there was a press conference just
two days ago you can see senator Markey
there and representative Liu and a
number of groups including Peace Action
and Union of Concerned Scientists
delivered 500,000 petitions now on let's
be clear this legislation will not pass
will not even be voted on but it is a
useful
it means to have this discussion so
useful means to get people to talk to
their office their representatives and
their Senate offices about this and and
we go from there okay we have a lot of
things that we need to change US policy
on we want to remove hair triggers for
land-based nuclear weapons or get rid of
the land-based nuclear weapons as mattis
suggested we and that will open up the
door to involving other people in a
decision to use weapons in response to
an attack you know even if there were an
attack you don't have to respond right
away unless you're worried about losing
your land-based missiles okay then we
have the issue of first youth options I
wouldn't say it's that we have a first
use policy but we have a policy of
retaining first youth options that's a
problem
and then there's the problem of
presidential authority so I just want to
take complicated a little bit and
explain to you that we have more
problems than you thought we did and
thank you I should say one more thing we
have on our website and I think there'll
be a few copies out there a very short
report on reducing the risk of nuclear
war you can get in on our website if
there aren't copies out there and that's
it
[Applause]
[Music]